hello everyone my name is Ruth I'm from
the European Parliament social media
team and I welcome you in Strasbourg
this is the time of the year when the
European Parliament Awards this annual
sacrifice prize for the freedom of
thought which is given to the
organizations and individuals that are
defending human rights and this year is
a special year because for the first
time this over it goes to the entire
population
to the brave people of Ukraine who are
represented by their president
elected officials and civil society and
who are together basically fighting the
adjusted
not justified Russian aggression of
course in their country so from helping
people on the spot rescuing people
giving them support
recording and collecting all the crimes
that I made from Russian army these are
just a few examples of what Ukrainian
people are a facing every day and today
I'm very very honored to be joined by
several of our laureates who will be
telling us their stories from their
point of view so I welcome our free
guest today and the first one is
Alexandra maticuk she is the lawyer a
human rights Defender and the chair of
the center of civil liberties and NGO
and then the mayor of melipatal melito
Paul I'm sorry who was abducted by the
Russian army Ivan federov
and also yaroslav bushko who is the
spokesperson of the yellow ribbon civil
resistance movement so thank you thank
you all of you really to to join us
today and agree to answer some questions
from me and also from our viewers so
this is also a reminder to all of you
who are watching us on YouTube LinkedIn
and Facebook if you have any questions
to our guests please leave them in the
comment section above and I'll be asking
them a few of them to our guest today
so let's start with couple of questions
from from my side well uh since 24th of
February you Alexandra Alexandra you
along with a team of volunteers
paralegals lawyers you have been
recording the the war crimes that are
made by the Russian army can you tell us
more about your work about the cases you
registered maybe you could give us some
examples
after a large scale and region we Face
recent presidential level of war crimes
and in order to document them we built
all Ukrainian networks of local
documentators we United several dozens
of organizations most Originals one into
this network and now we are able to work
on the ground directly record
testimonies of victims and witness and
mobile groups to the the occupied areas
gather at information from the ground
make other photos videos also we
analyzing open sources with a further
verification we have an ambitious goal
to document each War crime episode which
was committed by Russian troops in the
smallest Village in incho Blast in
Ukraine we we do it for that fact that
we believe that sooner or later
all Russians who committed these crimes
as well as Putin and the rest senior
political leadership and high military
command will be brought to Justice and
our evidence our information will be a
solid ground for the future court cases
thank you baby later on you can also
give us more examples and tell us more
about other cases and
um Mr fedorov you were
you actually became a symbol of
resistance of local self-government
since the start of the war and on the
11th of March you were abducted by the
Russian army could you tell us your
story situation the situation is next
24th of February Russian troops come to
our city a border of our city and by
next few days fully occupied and of
course the Russian troops think that
citizens representative city government
will give support for Russians and it
will be easy for Russians to take
control for the city but after 10 months
of occupation Russian control our city
Only physical but there is no support
from citizens from city government and
of course City Representatives when
Russian understands that we don't want
to cooperate with them we don't want to
give them support they try to show
example for azamers for US
representatives and make decision
kidnapped me and hold me on a prison and
of course that was rather hard six days
of my life because I can't understand
what I can't expect and I can't take any
information what can be why I'm on a
prison
who can make some negotiation about my
exchange and other things but most
important then after 10 months of
occupation more than 700 citizens only
from melatopo kidnapped and more than
100 of militar citizens now on a prison
some of them in Moscow in leforte some
of them in temporarily occupied it
Crimea and all of us know that every
citizens of Ukraine who kidnapped by
Russian tortured tortured by very
different ways Visa electricity cyclical
physical because for Russians civilians
life costs zero that's why all their
entries that they have they show on our
citizens
and yourself you were also tortured or
all citizens who kidnapped altars
um
can you tell us a little bit about this
yellow ribbon civil resistant movement
where the spokesperson of this
organization can you tell us more about
it how did it begin where how did it
start as well
I should see that the yellow ribbon
resistance movement is an organization
that works on occupied territory of
Ukraine in Carson melatopo
energies
danielsk Crimea and so on and so on we
have more than three thousand of
activists in different cities in
different Villages uh a lot of them was
beaten some of them was arrested and
several peoples are killed but we still
have not normal opportunity to create a
list we have not so many information
about uh
realis of the Russian occupation regime
on these territories and I should say
that we create our organization as a
tool to help Ordinary People to save the
Ukrainian identity in occupation to see
if the Ukrainian mindset to help them to
find the way how they can be useful for
their country in this time because we
understand not all the people have this
opportunity to become a soldier or an
officer of the Ukrainian armored forces
but we give this tool
help to people make them understanding
that their work are needed by their
country
a lot of them are just an ordinary
people and you will never say that this
guy or this girl will act like a hero
but it's reality you don't need to be a
hero to be a real hero at all
our idea of
organization is depends on
human dignity
Freedom understanding of uh we all
ukrainians need territorial integrity
and sovereignty of Ukraine uh supporting
democracy uh
human rights and
policies that based on their values
we need this policy based on the values
also for West because a lot of
politicians from West they only talk
about oh we can do anything for Ukraine
because we have some contracts with
Russia we will have a problem with an
energetical sector and so on and so on
but uh time's up
there are
tense months of full-scale invasion of
Russia and we still not have uh military
uh fly Jets from the Western countries
we still not have uh modern uh tanks we
need more air defense systems and so on
and so on and we need to change this
political agenda that uh stopped us from
getting this uh
things for Ukrainian Army
you mentioned the hero so we should
admit that every Ukrainian is a hero now
well there are Alexandra your initiative
which is called Tribunal for Putin has
already registered 17
000 criminal acts by the Russian army do
you expect these cases to reach the
Hague tribunal one day or I know that
you're also working on a strategy to
create some sort of separate
International Tribunal for for Russian
criminals and maybe can you explain us a
little bit the condition or conditions
of establishing such a tribunal we
jointly required it only for the nine
months of large-scale innovation 27
thousands episodes of our crimes and 27
thousands is a huge amount but it's only
tip of Iceberg because Russia uses her
crimes as the masses of fear Russia
deliberately tried to make suffering and
pain to Ukrainian civilians in order to
break resistance and occupy the country
so we record the pain we record not just
violation of Geneva and her convention
and us to provide examples in your
previous question I will tell a little
bit from my own experience because I
personally interviewed hundreds of
people who survived Russian captivity
and they told me horrible stories how
they were beaten how they were raped how
their fingers were cut how their nails
were turned away how the nails were
drilled how they were tortured with
electricity how they were compelled to
write something with their own blood
one woman told me how here I read a coat
with a spoon so it's really horrible
stories and there is no military purpose
in doing inside things Russians have
done these horrible things only because
they could so we now speak about culture
of impunity because Russian troops
committed war crimes in chichnia in
Moldova in Georgia in Mali in Libya in
Syria in other countries of the world
and they have never been accountable for
this
so we must break the circle of impunity
in order to do it we have to fill the
Gap accountability what do I mean for
current moment National legal system is
overloaded with an extreme amount of
crimes
but international criminal court which
efforts is very essential but he it will
limit its investigation only to several
select cases and international criminal
court has no jurisdiction over the crime
of aggression so the question is
who will provide Justice for hundreds of
thousands of victims of this war
and in order to achieve this goal we
need to elaborate a complex Justice
strategy we need to establish a special
tribunal on aggression and I know that
European Parliament plan to vote a
special resolution in this regard so I
asked European Parliament to vote in
favor and say Yes accountability for
Crime of aggression because there is no
other institution who can judge for such
kind of crimes and also we need to find
a way how to bring International element
into the level of national investigation
and National judges Justice
in order to provide each person their
chance for Effective investigation and
and Justice and we have to create a
model where International judges will
work together with national judges where
International investigators will work
together with national investigators so
this is something which we need doing
jointly with International Community and
you are working on it yes we are working
on it and because like after several
months of large-scale innovation I start
to ask to myself for whom do we document
all these crimes for
who will use this material
like I work directly with victims and I
know for sure that these people who went
through the hell
they need to restore not only their
broken lives at broken visions of the
future they need to restore their belief
their Justice is possible even though
delayed in time
see how saying according to how
significant is the role of
self-government in organizing the
resistance in the occupied territories
maybe you can how important is this
self-government in organizing the
resistance in the occupied territories
like can you maybe you can give us aside
on how they're dealing with the with the
current situation how with this
resistance because we need we need to
understand that organization of
resistance and organization with City
Management on occupied territories it is
a no new experience and it is those
tasks that we cannot believe ever that
we will need to solve first of all about
resistance it's really an unpredictable
thing that we saw from first days of
occupation our citizens go to Central
squares go to Central streets and show a
granted resistance on the meeting by
three four five thousand of Civilian
citizens without weapons without guns
they show soldiers of Russians that they
don't want to live on a Russian
Federation with occupation and they are
not glad that Russian come to our
territory and what's the main that until
10 months of occupation nobody clever
person in melitopen agreed to give
support to Russia and as an example that
collaboration in melitopal rather less
for example Knuckles agreed to give
support to Russian no one chief of
kindergarten from 21 kindergarten
military agreed to give support from
Russian know anyone wise mayor know
anyone chief of Department nobody wants
to
give or take Thompson is the same with
Russians this is why it's a greatest
decision because all our citizens want
to live in Democratic Ukraine and the
European Union Elsa what about
organization drop of city council now
city government now it's uh rather
unstandable job because now we have
three cities because city is first of
all the Citizens first part of our
cities and live in temporary occupied
territories and we try to give support
for them deliver some food some
humanitarian some Pharmacy it is very
laboring but we interest with
electricity and other services and it's
its first category second category is
also our citizens which now say all over
Ukraine and and of course keep in touch
with our citizens and third category is
those citizens who stay in the European
Union or another countries turkey
Georgia and Elsa of course we keep in
touch with them and it's also our heroes
because they our volunteers and they our
ambassadors in those citizens they go to
the city council they push for city
council and try to take humanitarian aid
for those citizens who now occupied
territories and it's like a hand of
service and paper ahead the main
position the back to melitopal as far
isn't possible as soon as possible
uh well Mr boschko uh how can you tell
us more how do these local groups of
people in this temporary occupied
territories they get mobilized and how
do they practically help you the the
movement like maybe you can give us some
examples from uh first of all
organization yellow ribbon create a
some different types of an action some
of them was to stop the Russian
semi-called referendum on the occupied
territories some of them are showing
showing that these cities are still
Ukrainian cities people paint the
Ukrainian national colors people paint
this symbol yellow ribbon people paint
Ukrainian Trident for example on the
wall of this
10 social atomization of people to
understand that you will support Russia
Russia would like to take you in this
situation when you understand
that you are alone with your own ideas
you are alone with your own Ukrainian
Indian identity so it will be maybe
better to change it to Russian to uh
save your life and so on and so on we
give to the Ordinary People this idea to
help him successful Ukraine and so on
and so on first first of all we need to
understand that uh
people are very brave at the small
cities and the biggest cities
you shall never understand how people
Brave is until it happened really a lot
of people are from
different social groups different age
groups boss men and women
it's not matter
if people would like to live in a
successful modern free Ukraine they will
do anything and I see that by my own
eyes
and what are the main means of
communication with them are there any
special tools you use or special
channels or first of all we use the
different types of communications uh
signal Prima app uh sometimes telegram
one it was more safe but in general
you must understand that all groups of
resistance choose their own tactics to
keep them safe safe they better
understand what is going on in their
cities they choose actions for them only
by they understanding of situation
uh dear Alexandra and actually it's a
question to to all of you what was your
reaction when you heard that the
European Parliament decided to award the
Ukrainian people with this year's sucker
of price for freedom of thought I know
you also received the Nobel Prize as
well so uh what is your feeling about it
and
um what was your reaction to that I was
very proud and I think that it's very
important that this a word received the
Ukrainian people not well
at home because
I will tell you how it was after
large-scale Invasion because immediately
International organizations evacuated
their stuff
and it were ordinary people who stay and
do their work on the ground it were
ordinary people who took people out from
their wind cities it were ordinary
people who helped to survive under
artillery's Fire it's where ordinary
people who broke encirclement to deliver
humanitarian Aid or who rescued people
who trapped under the rubbles of
residential buildings so Ordinary People
did an ordinary thing the huge wave of
solidarity like joined the whole country
and I will never wish any Nation to go
through the worries worry something
unhuman but these dramatic times provide
us opportunity to express our best
features to fight for freedom to be
courageous to take responsibility
to make tough but right choices to be
creative and find Creative Solutions so
I'm very happy that European Parham and
recognize the efforts of Ukrainian
people and encourage all of us with this
award so that this is a general place
for everybody
um how how what was your reaction what
um it is very important about
and now it's very on time because we
need to every day to show support for
our europation and European Institution
for our citizens especially for Citizens
on occupied territory they really really
Heroes they really show resist until 10
months but uh
Russians Tried by help of their
propaganda clean the mind of our
citizens and show that Ukraine never
come back European Union forgot about
about you and we need new and new Awards
new and new support from our patents for
our citizens and this is really about on
time
and a reaction from the movement
organization
it's a chance to say thanks Jacob uh
fall people who support Ukraine as the
occupied territories who take part in
actions of the yellow ribbon and another
resistance movement because
guys you are strong and you become
stronger from day to day and Ukraine
will win this war
well we also well we know that you
already has imposed some various
sanctions on Russia
provided support to Ukraine like or many
Europeans they open their houses their
homes all around Europe
what more in your opinion can each of us
do in order to support Ukraine and
Ukrainian people I will use this
opportunity to express sincere gratitude
to people in different countries and to
EU itself for the support which we
received during this dramatic part of
our history
we are grateful but the truth is that in
order to defeat Putin and stop this war
in Europe we need more because if we
will not be able to stop Putin in
Ukraine he will go further and it means
that we need more weapons we need more
sanctions and we need Justice like I
will provide you example uh
week and a half ago my friend Ukrainian
Defender Adriana sussak
was blow up in a mine in civilian car
so I ask myself
why it's happened when so many countries
over you have their armored vehicles in
their storages why in the nine months of
this large-scale invasion over Ukrainian
Defenders have still to conduct their
duties in a civilian car
so like also we heard about this
pinpoint with leopardo battle tanks and
every day of delay and discussions
resulted in numerous deaths of Ukrainian
Defenders people in the occupied
territories and people in deep rear
so we have no time to wait
we need modern weapon now look Russia
continue their touristic attack to
critical civil infrastructure and this
night they also provide more burdened of
my native City Kiev and I started my
morning with texting to my relatives are
they okay and if I have a flat to return
so we need weapons immediately
and there are a lot of discussion
whether or not like sanctions after this
glass of water is half full of half
empty but the right question is
do we have enough water in this glass to
stop the ability of Russian economy to
feed this war
and the answer is no
not yet so we need more
what would be your message what what do
you think not only governments but also
people from Europe what can what can
they do to support today we speak about
this topic a lot and the main message
it's next to push on their government
because now we see the statistic and
statistics States about the greatest
support from
citizens of different countries European
Union different cities that citizens
want to give support to Ukraine and it
is the main the Citizens need to push
for their governments for their
representatives to give this support as
quickly as it possible because Ukraine
needs this support now Ukrainian
Citizens need support now because we
defend and we border for European Union
that's why Citizens need to go and push
their governments as quickly as it
possible
oil we need to bend Russia's guests we
need to bans Russia's money in Europe uh
we need to bance Russia's infrastructure
of the political corruption uh all
around the world uh all countries of the
world should help Ukraine Ukraine will
win but the main questions is how many
people will be killed until this moment
so
we need your support we need your
weapons we need your sanctions we need
serious political business well thank
you that was a very really interesting
interview thank you very much for your
answers I'm sure all of us already know
a lot about what's happening in Ukraine
but it's always good to hear uh to hear
it from you as well uh when we announced
that the brave Ukrainian people were
awarded with this sucker for uh price we
received really many comments and many
supporting messages so let me just name
a few of them for example miktaki from
Instagram is saying glory to the brave
people of Ukraine be fighting for Europe
and our freedom or jikos is saying
cannot imagine a Conte baradas from
Instagram is saying for the first time I
feel proud to be European I used to be
skeptical about the you but today I feel
so incredibly proud of our you for doing
the right thing recognizing The Bravery
and resilience of the amazing Ukrainian
people
Teresa from LinkedIn is saying
congratulations to the people of Ukraine
fighting for the freedom and United
against War as well as Paulo is saying I
have the greatest admiration for the
determination and resilience of the
European Ukrainian people for the
Democratic Values so he's sitting
supporting you supporting Ukraine and
again thank you very much for for your
time I know your agenda is very busy
today
and everybody that wants to watch this
interview again you will find it on our
Facebook page and you can watch it
anytime you want so thank you thank you
thank you very much